this will go pretty quickly hi guys
welcome to this video here with mamrie
and Hannah and beans in his prom season
and so what a better opportunity for us
to compete again this is really similar
to the Halloween costume challenge that
we do here on this channel I thought be
really fun for us to challenge ourselves
to create some prom looks oh I wanted to
call this our prom competition oh so
there's gonna be three rounds each round
will be doing another element that is
necessary for a prom losing your
virginity first round is going to be a
makeup look I love how much you guys
gasp Diane has so wonderfully organized
that we each have one of these Beauty
Revolution makeup kits and we're gonna
have three minutes in round one to
create our look is there everything you
need in this one little kit and we're
not sponsored but that would be an
amazing moment first time is makeup the
second round is a corsage and the third
round is finally the outfits already
probably when you're ready to go Diane's
ready look about all three two one
coverage hell of a case
oh no it's not the color I thought this
is also how we eat food amazing so I'm
gonna be artsy 1000 already three two
one
what do you I contoured hi Tammy Faye
Baker lovely I went with the throwback
of what I had and pretty sure was my
actual prom
oh yeah you really put a fake mole I
wish a little hard I love I got hard I
tried to contour but then I still had a
little blue oh here's my question are
corsages the things do yes that's the
next round is making Chris honest if you
don't know corsages are like a floral
arrangement for your wrist yeah it makes
no sense so very yeah try make
boutonniere of course you can make
anything you want of course not just any
linear inside these boxes or baskets
there are three items you take just a
quick second and I'll look through and
then we'll start right after hey open oh
alright cleaner later various printed
tissue okay three oh wait one go
yeah it has a unique smell maybe it's
the play-doh oh man we stop it no
memories going for something good
how much time do we have left a lot yeah
let's up it at three minutes just with
your board yeah very sweaty this is some
great ASMR ah now I'm Mouse chops like
when that cocky person is like just
cleaning after station and then they
like go over and like have a swig of
like cooking wine right and then they
find out that they didn't like you use
none of your ingredients I went with
just a nonsense abstraction at first
then I realized it looked like a
dinosaur not like you know
Jurassic Park is really popular YouTube
you all love Chris Pratt yeah people
called us dinosaurs yeah I definitely
hate the film good dinosaur don't get
started I gotta think of a name for
dinosaur corsage and also it looks like
if your prom date got too frisky yeah
you could just feel out their eyes I'm
the kind of girl that makes this you
want to get frisked yeah that should be
there like yes food memory but yeah I
would classic beautiful rose as you see
I use the pipe cleaners to secure the
row and then just don't like it
tie up the edges I took a little polka
dots and just tape a little edge so you
didn't have to make me I wouldn't wear
that
that's our utiful s almost as beautiful
as this cute near oh my god but it's the
top of it supposed to be in the young
vagina
I was like a person yeah and if you
can't see these look so really coming
together like New Wave eighties let's go
are you inside 1983 you know oh okay we
are into round 3 which is the ensemble
or prom sample we all have these
beautiful flattering pink mousse to work
with I love these and then we have three
other things in our basket that we have
to use in our prom Samba along with
whatever in the pantry that we watch
okay here we go
very hot my hello your colleges
I'm sorry Oh
I went for all who wears dressed a
little too [ __ ] for high school I
don't what I did is I took these sponges
and stuck them under my boobs a little
more further left tied up this bad boy
gave myself a cinched waist and then a
little accent here that ties into my I
brushed it may read it's so good through
the shirts when you edit this I tried to
continue to theme of dinosaur I also
made a romper like a prom I do have some
nice shiny in detail in the back I drew
blindly he also put some greed on the
table yeah yeah just a little longer but
just a little on my butter you can that
there was all part of the look
I went through and I gave myself a cover
of eyes beautiful bow tie I use my
Squishy fake this shoulder pal Kuta near
these buttons obviously obviously and
additionally I brought a facade for my
date I'm broke but it feels right I
definitely put my even though we won
some of us have lost it other Queens are
looking down on every guys I think we're
all good thank you guys for
participating in this prom come let us
know who you think had the best prom
look don't forget to subscribe to have a
memory for other Chanel Ian's on their
Channel and we'll see you guys hopefully
not at any of your problems I got 99
problems and an outfit I want this is
where things get interesting J and it's
nice they RT I know I feel like I played
it too safe looking at your face I don't
know if there's anything safe about that
mole